[Musique]
l'accordéon jeun dans les cours l'enfant
divin vous tire la barbe le vent du nord
s'accroche aux arbres 1,6 annonce le
printemps
venaient vers nous oppose enfants enfant
perdu tant de risques est
mettez les fleurs à vos casquettes
selon l' usage des truands les margotin
des jours de fêtes fleurissent la lourde
des bougnats voici le surplus les
marques à de la chapelle à la villette
voici les greluches de paris les
vieilles dettes mon marque noise et
leurs souvenirs rajeuni cet automne la
rue qui pavoise
en remontant la rue lepic on glisse vers
le passé
le souvenir reprend ses droits la
nostalgie s'éveille il manque ablement
il était une fois une butte qu'on
appelait montmartre les peintres et les
poètes lautrec van gogh renoir carco
picasso mac orlan ont illustré son livre
d'or des heures qui furent insouciante
et vivent si l'on en croit la légende
tout se passe comme si la réalité de la
rue était alors le plus beau des
spectacles la fiction s'en est emparé et
le cinéma bien sûr dans son film french
cancan jean renoir fils d'auguste le
peintre sacrifie à son tour à la légende
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui place du tertre les toiles
sont tourner d'abord vers les touristes
la légende s'est dégradée en folklore et
les vieux montmartrois se sentent
étrangers dans leur propre quartier
l'esprit de la butte survit pourtant
dans une petite maison blanche en face
du moulin de la galette il se nomme jean
paul et il est peintre lui aussi
il ya combien de temps que vous vivez
ici à montmartre se fait depuis que je
suis né j'y suis né
puis 95
olfeo 96 je crois que il ya tableau
d'ailleurs de la maison vous est pris
face à un tableau peint par go en vol
c'est le maulana ya un moulin et puis
dans le fond il ya une petite maison
avec une lucarne c'est là où je suis né
et la lucarne ça correspondait à quoi ça
correspond d un logement pas cher
je suis un peu immature et
ma mère à l'époque les jeunes filles
quand elles se trouvaient avant club il
fallait qu'elle planquent leur grossesse
c'était très mal vu même dans le peuple
alors elle se serraient il y avait le
cou du corps celle dont j'ai été victime
du corps cod parme ainsi bien que wolf
je suis né à 7 mois
et c'est la fruitière du rez de chaussée
qui maquillage ou chez ma mère
en fin de compte il ya une copie qui est
venu qui lui a dit en temps quand même
pu prévoir une s'acheva lendemain la
sage femme est venue et
lissa pas là demain
ils me voyaient
dans le fond je crois que je suis un
enfant de la moins cinq ans
le maire avait rencontré mon bios ou la
mégane est ce beauf un tour de valse et
puis voilà un coups de traversins et
l'alpe au pôle tv au monde ce n'est pas
une belle
suite bonaventure
alors après moi j'étais un enfant
naturel pendant très longtemps
il m'a mais avait pris un métier à part
le métier de gros dossiers td les soeurs
de saint vincent de paul
actuellement
déjà en bayod elle me déposer à la
crèche m plusieurs prendre le soin elle
partait le matin 7h30 rentrer à huit
heures du soir
enfin j'ai grandi à la maternelle et un
jour là sur le lit et on peut pas y
aller ton fils dossier des baptisés
alors
elle m'a fait baptiser
puis alors à l'époque où si on portait
des jupes les garçons portaient des
jupes
c'était comme ça alors jour là sur lui à
dire
pour la méta pantalon à ton fils
monsieur quand il fait des galipettes en
lui voit son oiseau
et ba a précisé la communale
il a communal banques s'en sort j'ai
passé mes trois bacs à l'école
de rugby
comment vous étiez bonne élève non pas
du tout
j'ai été mordu par le dessin quand même
des eaux reste
[Musique]
je prenais tout comme celle de laura et
c'est une question d'oreille sa blessure
ce n'est de voir les mêmes la présence
des rendez-vous au compteur
les vacances les deux mois de vacances
je les passais dans le préau de l'école
de rugby
les jeudis jeux les possédants le
pétrole à l'appui que j'en avais marre
l'école biblique à douai 12 ans et demi
j'ai demandé à me mettre au boulot
c'était comme ça j'avais jamais vu ni la
mère ni la montagne
je me souviens quand même
quand j'étais môme
mais comme ma vieille partait le matin
pique à l'entrée le soir il me filait
dans la rue il veut laisser jamais des
clés avait toujours peur que je veux je
met le feu ou alors si elles mais elles
meurent a laissé des clés genre jamais
amené une bande de copains l'âne d'or
noir et tout saccagé
et des fois quand il faisait trop froid
il me dit ah quand même tu pourras où
elle en ciel donné mes chaussures à
ressemeler alors elle me laisser vos
pajot
je vous rappelle j'avais un édredon
rouge que j'ai pu faire dans ses droits
dont c'est une chose magnifique j'ai
fait je crois le tour du monde avec 1gb
mais t'es dans la lune dans
je faisais des trous des bosses dans
édredon et je m'imaginais tout ce que je
voulais et par la suite quand j'ai pu
voyager
et ben le pittoresque ça m'est jamais
passé
j'ai tout ce que je voyais basses
étaient au dessous de ce que j'avais je
m'étais imaginé dans les rues dont
du pij
à l'actuel moi j'avais jamais vu la mer
ni la montée il est non pas par ici il y
avait tout ce qu'il fallait c'était un
peu c'est un peu la campagne quand même
le quartier c'était désert c'était 50 et
par personne et avec les d'abord ces
deux
c'était comment déjà habité par des se
voyait les jours il partait le matin
rentrait le soir alors il y avait les
rapports étaient les points l'appeler
sereine ça va tout seul on les voyait
dans les geôles mais quelqu'un qui se
baladait dans le quartier dans la
journée on se demandait on disait mais
enfin il n'y a pas de patron ce mec là
ils étaient douteux
c'était un mec à monter à l'échafaud tu
as fait
c'est un criminel un body on fait tout
ce qu'on peut il fallait avoir un patron
il y avait des rats pain célèbre bah oui
la belle y avait des rats peint ces
derniers sont devenus célèbres elle est
possible et c'est pas du tout
gelé c'est à dire une gelée pour connu
moi j'ai constaté tout moment mais je le
voyais passer je sais pas j'avais devais
avoir 4 50 quelque chose comme ça j'en
ai déjà medrano un stage là des
fureteurs j'avais pris le
lautrec je l'avais pris pour un clone de
medrano
gth en lieu de penser qu'il était
j'étais un grand peintre
et par la suite que j'ai appris
mais il était grotesque
il était en forme possible toujours nu
très élégant mais il était dit forme
battu douanes en a vu d
[Musique]
j'avais la goulue ah non là volus ses
pointes et théoricien alors des dents
alors que leur fils
dans la dossier ça c'est l'époque de ma
vieille ce
vieillard a pu être raconté 10,6 soit
sur la volée sur le moulin rouge sur le
moulin de la galette est
probant
[Musique]
pour
où
la panne incendie du moulin rouge
on a conseil de la route
je possède devant l'entrée du bal et
c'est ce que je vois jouer à la goulue
rester en chaussons elle avait une
petite
pièce attachée qu'une ficelle autres
yacine et par une ficelle autour du cou
elles vont aller les caramels
tu voi a voulu quand même qu'il y avait
eu ces l'arête du moulin rouge elle est
passée là je vais poser lui jacques
c'est souvent prend lé passé l'un puis
talus penser à beaucoup de choses
il est reparti en traînant ses chaussons
qu'est ce qu'il a pu le passer dans la
tronche à ce moment là
elle avait sa baraque là sur le
boulevard de clichy alors c'est l'abbé
sa ménagerie
sais pas si aux barbes et le mental la
baisse et ménager
bassila ménages a été décoré par
l'hotrec t'as jamais entendu parler de
ça ça n'est pas qu'un ménage chez elle
et ses danseuses la fille lise honteuse
et celle de samara qui était décoré par
l'hotrec elle a vendu sa baraque et on a
retrouvé tous les lots trail dans un
hangar
naturellement que ça protège pas été
perdu pour tout le monde la presse s est
découpé en morceaux et baissé dans tous
les musées maintenant mais la goulée
alors même là mon vieux une et place
blanche - il n'y en face du moulin rouge
et là j'allais faire les lourdes là
quand j'étais môme c'est là où j'allais
ouvrir les portières pour faire quelques
ronds quoi enfin pour moi la place
blanche sa colère des blouses blanches
ça compte pour moi
il ya la rue lepic c'était quoi la rue
lepic allait pas écouter la rue lepic
tout de même c'est la rue
c'est un peu la colonne vertébrale la
fin du quartier et ça peu tordu mais
enfin parce que la place blanche
jusqu'aux sacré-coeur
et j'avoue me prête une guadeloupe et
que ses vaches
souvent by a eu vent boy qui habille
c'est la
course lynch habitait là
au lieu destiné aux 96 sur le pays si
j'étais né à plougastel soirée c'est une
affaire si j'arrêtais gloire de plus de
plougastel t il ça marche pas on voit
internat trop c'est trop
enfin j'ai pas un enfin c'est ça mon de
la rue le pays
il était comme ça le moulin de la
galette oui ils l'ont démolie d'encoder
l'histoire yale
et la table
abbas a c'est la gaillette de les liens
du moulin l'oeil allait craquer juste en
face de ma maison
s'est installé où ça en face à face la
ronde la rampe qui montent haut
on appelle ça les jardins de
mont-de-marsan
[Musique]
bon
il ya même publié avec une musique
maintenant c'est du disque chez moi j'ai
été bercé alors avec les flonflons de
les valses y avait brel toffel kbis
elles achoppent assistant entendu parler
de ce compositeur la valse des fautes il
y avait ma bile alors moi j'ai été bercé
main avec les flonflons de dumoulin des
galets
soit c'est la maison de mémé pinson a
été appelé la maison nuit pas changé
aussi c'est à la suite de succès de
louise charpentier ou ceux ci il faut le
chlore m'enfin louis c'est pas mal fait
c'est pas mal comme musique
al ala d'un peuple
c'est l'impasse traîner je me suis
toujours demandé pourquoi on appelait ça
la poste rennais et ben une traînée
c'est un piège à loup
ça s'adapte de quelle époque à peu près
de toujours ça je vois dans le fond la
bassée
sont des écuries
et à gauche il ya là un grand terrain
vague et je me rappelle que le maire a
bissé à droite allait les fenêtres
donnaient sur ce fameux terrain où il y
avait de la lumière vous avez des gerbes
aux folles
alors voilà les nanas du quartier des
médias il ya cinquante piges les grands
y est elles sont toujours là
mais rien de moi ça l'est les chasse
comme à vingt ans
vous l'aviez reconnu mois le vert comme
une petite fille louis
xiv
[Rires]
tu as connu quand il y avait la pompe à
feu
tu as connu quand il y avait des
aviateurs ou sinon tout va bien je
comprends bien dans le terrain vague
n'a pas connu toi l'amour demain sinon
six cavités l'âme j'ai connu tous
elle était belle
c'est l'histoire d des crocs le monde
mais
un jour ils l'ont ramené ce qui tapinent
a
été belle comme un beauty c'est de lire
une vraie bière jantes alu elle était
très belle une vraie beauté
est
actuellement quel travail et puis un
jour le travail est plus l [ __ ] aux
barbes un jour les flics l'ont ramené à
poil des noms
mais une pèlerine pour la pour la
rentrée chez elle un jour il s'était
fait réélire houllier par son julie non
plus de croo
elle renaît dans aller toute l'étendue
devons dire alors redescendu au turf et
le faisait d'elle sauvier d'aidé dans
meet pa pour ce petit elle avait 20 ans
alors dans le quartier quand j'étais
môme je faisais le guide
c'est une nature
je faisais monter au dos du sacré coeur
lors des visites et le
le toit du moulin de la galette
et puis on me demandait souvent la tombe
de la dame aux camélias
alors je descendais juste le cimetière
rennes dol et des ronds
tout ça c'était des petites combines de
jeunesse de mômes pour pouvoir
l'entendre on
n'attend s'échapper de l'école alors on
allait dans les rues y avait des
terrains mais y
avait gelé les appels et les mollets des
failles avaient tous les oiseaux il y
avait des chauves souris il y avait des
décès rondelle matin y'a plus rien tout
est fini allez on te voyais
l'encombrement de voiture qui a dans le
coin
bien une chose que je me souviens quand
même
c'est que mon grand-père s'est pendu aux
110 et la dr maison de la rue lepic
la maison où habitait
jean-baptiste-clément
et
mon grand père guy charpentier en bateau
il était venu à paris à pied de saint
malo
% brochot sacré-coeur la construction du
sacré coeur
de l'époque
allait parler des sécurité sociale y est
quand il y avait pas d g
quelques boulots
de l'accident
avait pas de pognon des maladies je
crois pas que c'est pour un homme est
malade mais enfin si les accidentés
touchent et pas l'argent
et j'ai entendu dire par ma mère je pars
les hivers rigoureux
il partait à pied des hauts bois de
boulogne là pour balayer les pistes de
patinage pour trois balles et on
revenait à pied aller retour et après de
montmartre il a conçu les usines de
saint denis les usines à gaz et par
celle matin à pied à saint-denis
revenait le soir à pied
alors je croyais qu'il ya eu tout de
même un peu de progrès 1
il s'est pendu pourquoi pas de misère
il a été accidenté et puis là je ne
pouvais plus travailler c'est un homme
qui était très costaud une mesure est je
crois un mètre 88
on l'appelait la tour eiffel dans le
quartier
est en pleine santé s'est mis en l'air
elle était accidenté puis ne pouvait pu
reprendre sa charpente
c'est comme ça quoi c'est dans le
naturellement que tout ça ça s'est
amélioré bon il ya eu beau j'ai bien
mais à l'époque on considérait dans si
on était dans la tourbe j'étais comme ça
quoi
c'est quoi la storm ben là je trouve ce
débat si le contraire de
la richesse qua
non
mais comment vit on vivait à cette
époque là
bas où il veut tu sais envie aux gens le
jour
j avais pas de
qom avait pas de sécurité sociale fait
les multifonctions et chinois
ça empêche pas que
le trade chantait quand même
puis je suis là des coûts de 14 juillet
quand même
je trouve qu'ils étaient plusieurs mains
de temps
à temps ils ont les préoccupations
navire de
l époque comme tout le monde était paumé
à s'il y avait des grosses you know ce
qu'on appelle la belle époque alors
nouvelle et mais comment
des calèches quand même dans paris
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et à l'époque une chance on savait
l'importance
les chansons j'ai été la nourriture du
peuple qui continue quand il sentait
trop malheureux vaïsse fils à une
complainte
et s'arranger le coup c'est ça les
chansons
bon
je reste a toujours été comme ça
les chansons d'amour va lui dire est la
télévision ne parle que de la chance
plumeau les mecs m'ont à mes jetons
coeur mon coeur
revient
tu m'as qui ces
retours
les 6 médailles à losail ils ont des
rôles sans platines devant leurs lourdes
et qu'est ce qu'ils payent la rolls
c'est la petite moulinette
cet abbé sandwich à déjeuner tu
comprends pour se payer un disque
et loyal mais comprend la poste qui
roule alors froid tant les conneries
je veux pas dire des nombres
mais à l'époque à montmartre il n'y
avait pas de disque encore comment à
l'époque à montmartre il n'y avait pas
de disque encore alors comment les
apprenait les chanceux dans la rue je
vais les chanteurs des rues
à tous les carrefours y avait des
il faudrait la chanson
il y en a qui lisent apprenez comme ça
tout ça c'était en chanter en choeur et
vous en souvenez vous
j'ai jamais beaucoup de
mémoire pour les pour la championne est
quand même
lui n'attend comores
et le souhait
revenez
dans l'espoir que poté
dans les bras d'un autre un jour tu
souffriras
et que vers le
tueur
c'est con mais en fait moi ça se vendait
[Rires]
il ya une chanson de carco aussi à long
mais ça c'est autre chose c'est de la
poésie
ça c'est dans le domaine des poètes à
autre chose
des poèmes qui sont mis en musique c'est
toute chose il ya en général l'art
avec ses maisons blême
[Musique]
ces trottoirs luisant et sert hazard
toujours
les mêmes nous savons tous pourquoi il
aime depuis le temps de sa bohème
dunkerque une buse eva deux ans
mais grubby
voire de misère
montmartre l'hiver le printemps
y avait il chanté ne
[Musique]
bouge prix de recharge
il ya des fois tu ton parcours
de la chasse
certaines mélodies
aujourd'hui tout ce que tu entends c'est
sûr n'est
désir de travailler à la mouillère en
effet quand c'est pas tout ça sur une
musique un peu
à s'agiter la croupe à césar
mais à l'époque c'était
j'avais des valses combien ils veulent
se chanter en feuilles avec les trente
ans
[Musique]
mais vous dansiez à l'époque commandant
non non je m'étais danseurs du conte
projet j'ai croisé les nouveaux des neuf
du bois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça jamais été bon genre ça
quand j'étais jeune du rideau notant les
hommes on n'avait pas le genre séducteur
te renvoie comme je te disais à vanter
comprend le rouleur de mécaniques le
vrai jules le mec quand même régulier
un peu de tendresse quand même hein
mais maintenant je suis devenu un tendre
c'est pas mal non
c'est quoi être tendre
bah je peux le faire
l'amour
les postes s'explique pas ça
tu vois tu peux pas le dire
tu te l'entend dire tu dis est ce que tu
es et endroit alors s'ébattent
moi je me reconnais plus
pourquoi vous n'êtes pas tendre
tout le monde
d'abord j'ai avec moi je suis pas tant
délictuelles
aux mêmes vieilles halles était pourtant
je crois qu'elle m'embrasser
ai pas le temps de m'embrasser
des fois il chercher un peu de chaleur
étant monde comme se doit j'ai pas le
temps
elle m'avait bien quand même
[Musique]
y avait la bande à bonnot aussi à
l'époque
oui mais à la bande à bonnot
basse et à son mal-être les flics ont
commencé à être armés
tous les flics avait un revolver
et ça j'ai eu une aventure
avec un de mes petits postes
et un copain un jour qui me dit j'étais
sans boulot un joueur nba ce que tu veux
je te fais un tour autour du retour au
bois de boulogne le tour du lac
tu dis on prend un taxi ont fait une
balade
camp nou la partie
alors je monte dans deux accidents
belle place clichy
juste en face gaumont lapinous la partie
au bois de boulogne fait le tour du lac
à des vrais caïds
sillard toutim
[Applaudissements]
puis on revient
dix ans va sûrement retourner place
clichy la garenne y avait un tour sur
les boulevards
avenues et places phishing dit j'ai pas
un rond quotidien je dis moi n'ont pu
dire qu'une chose l'avion va se poser
la question
moi aussi on saute on ouvre la portière
et 6 et aider les fameux deux pas trois
pattes chez pas les fameux taxis de la
marne
et moi je me tire à tout petit joint
vers le dalaï lama lodi là vers le pont
caulaincourt
puits lui-même fils de frein lui était
tout petit besoin d'un mètre cinquante
d'eux on l'appelait fifi la vertu il va
un peu les jambes arrière lendemain il
rhdp vis
puis blake hip hop sont bada à 10 ans il
laisse tomber son chapeau et un chapeau
ça coûtait à l'époque un larynx et
beauté car en dessous
alors bien sûr les lieux du crime pour
retrouver son chapeau port of two
mondiale au voleur au voleur le voleur
les deux voleurs
ça se transforme en assassin au lieu de
revenir vers moi ils filent vers la
place clichy
avec les flics au cul la foule au cul il
descend la rue de clichy
a dirigé la bande à bonnot et
y voit et tourne à gauche c'était un
impasse la rue du cannet ray cardinal
mercier d'ilan
arrivé au bout sans issue il mais si les
vingt pieds en vol vers la dame comme ça
il met sa main sa poche le flic le
descends je savais pas qu'il avait un
pétard mais
voilà et le soir dans l'est
on ne voyait dans les rues un émule de
la bande à bono en cherchant complice le
conflit s'était mise il
y avait trois balles au compteur
ici fait buter pour trois balles
mbia riche idée est monté
il était monté au front il sait failli
serait fait passer pour un pur
pour un rond alors ça tue ses trois
balles ça valait sous faible coût un
dernier soleil se couche ce pari au soir
du jour où jaurès a été assassiné au
matin du 2 autres le sort a le temps
deux instances
[Musique]
2 hier se déclarer
soudas nations les murs une affiche
par décret du président de la république
la mobilisation des armes et leurs
coordonnées ainsi que la répétition
animaux voiture et harnes est nécessaire
de complémente césar mais oui alors
meubles
puissant boulot
alors j'ai vendu des journaux on allait
faire la queue au croissant pour
avoir un sens de papier
et je me rappelle c'est parce que moi
j'étais alors un boîtier de première
classe alors j'étais parti comme jardim
jazy là quand j'étais môme
j'étais le premier annoncé la mort de
jaurès place pigalle quand tu parles que
mon papier laissez le en moins de deux
ans le verrou man 2
[Musique]
oui
un jour je me suis trouvée quand même
j'étais stur barre il cherchait la soupe
chez rothschild alors je me suis fait
engueuler par les grossesses et wii
était pas encore barré qu'est ce que tu
fous là moi ça cette bande de
dégueulasse il y avait déjà les veuves
des du premier mois de la guerre
alors comme j'étais bien balancé des
comprend il fallait y avait pas de
quartier
nous y envoyer de tort
j'avais 18 ans et demi
revient que je vois sur un canard j'ai
des voitures non des
demandes des vendangeurs cazouls les
béziers alors j'ai emballé d'abord
investir et de parier
mais vu comment on va y aller à pinceaux
on ira à pied d'abord on fera les
moissons en cours de route on se
débrouillera quoi y'a pus moyen de toni
ou alors fallait
j'envisageais pas de faire la guerre je
me sentais quand même un peu trop mou
gens il peut alors il fallait que je
m'en de la demande la permission à ma
mère je sais quand même mineur et ma
vieille alors ai jamais donné son
recensement
en fin de compte là qu'on ferme les
portes de paris absolue tous les jeunes
gens de 18 ans interdiction de sortir de
paris alors le nouveau la césar
alors la soupe à rothschild
le rigolade par les nanas qui ce que tu
fous là
tu serais mieux là haut est alors on
appliquer une thèse on est descendu au
bastion on s'est mis à poil et bon pour
le service
on m'a demandé où je voulais aller bâti
le plus loin possible c'est tout con con
qu'on s'était bien bien mis dans le
temps que la ja et durer 3 mois ou quoi
ou à berlin en moins de deux
j'ai plus loin possible ils nous ont
battus à l'est puisque comme je
m'engageais j'avais droit de choisir on
n'avait pas le droit de choisir vous
même une autre âme que l'habit fin de
calais duby fin du bifff 1 c'est quoi la
vie l'habitat si l'infanterie
alors
je dis le plus loin possible
quand j'entends les antilles dillon gee
à mon pote passion des parlements des
partis à 2
h 10 les antilles d'ici là et tant qu'on
haït la banque qui conviennent alors la
guerre sera finie
et que j'en sois ma feuille de route
c'est et antibes j'avais mal compris
enfin meubles la partie d'amour
à antibes
les qu'une tête au sens aux trois bâtons
ou sa onzième d'infanterie et voilà
l'histoire
pourquoi je suis pas comment je suis
parti à la guerre
mais anti vous avez vu la mer pour la
première fois quand j'ai débarqué a
descendu la gare saint-charles d'ainsi
paul agon
j'avais entendu parler de la canebière
alors je vois un flic julie pardon
monsieur la canebière aiguë est ce que
c'est une merde ça j'avais les pieds
dedans dire
face à ma peau est passé
et puis à marseille avant de partir
j'avais emprunté une thune quand même un
problème du quartier
on avait une thune à 2 pour partir à la
guerre bien sûr nous et
je suis arrivée là tu réellement ma
caserne
pour la peine de parler taille et apache
et c'est pas marrant
enfin au bout de cinq jours nous envoyer
en nous a fait monter en ligne
devait faire un coup dont nous amener au
champ de tir
moi j'avais jamais tenu un fusil si ou
fête foraine quoi puis alors un pétard
comme se remanier un peu le pétard dans
le quartier mais enfin pour se marrer
quoi pour s'en servir
et ben voilà
le premier village que j'ai vu c'est
fleurier d'hautmont j'avais jamais vu la
campagne n'ont pu alors là je fais
campagne
puis gens survenue
mais genre survenue avec une canne en
l'air
et le plus marrant glossy j'avais pas
été multi lots j'aurais jamais ses
parents
alors tu vas te le disent et c'est comme
ça quand vous êtes revenu de la guerre
vous étiez décorés
alors les touches décorer votre revient
de la guerre
nous en étions nous au moulin rouge je
crois
[Musique]
que tout le monde les décors et
non mais
on parlait du bel de moulin rouge non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voulait pas parler de la guerre
dans la guerre on l'a fait mais on n'en
parle pas
or ici c'était à refaire pour
qu'on dirait pas pêcher c'est toujours
la dernière
n'ont cependant
du rsa le passé c'est du passé
à la course
pour marrant hein dis la vérité
[Musique]
moi le passé ça m'intéresse pas et la
demi heure pas plus il ya un an je crois
que tu es en train de passer au pays
importants
lorsque je vois arriver le jour moi ça
ça de grande importance pour moi
dois je vais toujours ma toile être le
soir
je tiens toujours avoir des draps
propres
de manière si je ne me réveille pas le
lendemain que je sois en état que je
sois corey temps
mais la journée que
je la garde pour moi des membres je
l'emploie bien je veux pas qu'on la
prenne
[Musique]